[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a look inside the mind of accused sarah
lawrence cult leader lawrence wray
plus will one time socialite elaine
maxwell be granted a new trial what both
sides have to say on alleged juror
misconduct and we are starting the jury
selection process but i've been handed a
document indicating that an agreement
has been reached in the 11th hour
crystal daniels enters a plea deal in
connection to the death of her son baby
joe daniels but first a mother's
intuition if he didn't answer her call
or call her back he's not on this earth
the mother of nba star lorenzen wright
takes the stand as the accused murderer
stands trial law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin testimony begins in tennessee
where billy ray turner stands trial for
the murder of nba star lorenzen wright
as a prosecution's first witness the
slain basketball player's mother takes
the stand
lorenzon wright was reported missing in
july 2010 when he didn't return calls to
family members days later his body was
found in a tennessee woods near his
mother's home seven years after his
death the murder weapon was recovered in
a mississippi lake that's when defendant
billy ray turner was arrested and later
charged with wright's murder prosecutors
say wright's ex-wife shara wright
recruited turner and shot and killed her
ex-husband they say she was after the
basketball player's life insurance
policy sheriff wright was later charged
in connection to her ex-husband's murder
she's currently serving a 30-year
sentence for facilitating the murder as
the prosecution's first witness in the
turner trial lorenzen wright's mother
was called to the stand she explained
when she knew something was wrong and
how shera wright reacted to the news
that her ex-husband was missing
was there a point that you became
concerned that something had happened to
her
oh yes
he did return my call
because he he always returned my call
mad and lord that's why i waited till
the end to call to call lord because i
know if he hadn't gotten her back
himself wasn't right because he always
thought being happy
yes
i wish i could play the message i left
like where are you call me asap
and you didn't hear from me didn't hear
from didn't hear from nobody else had
heard from did you tell someone oh i
know i no i don't want to talk to her
last cause she defined her draw because
if he didn't answer her call or call her
back he's not on this earth
did what she tell you made any sense at
all none of it nothing makes sense did
it cause you to feel any certain way
like she knew something but wasn't
saying
later prosecutors showed the jury the
murder weapon and heard from detectives
about sheryl wright's reaction when it
was recovered
she reacted like it was
bad news
yes
how bad
she
was it was she could tell that she was
under a lot of stress that we had found
that firearm now the news is not just
the murder weapon and we're getting
close
but her murderer still invested
correct
did her attitude change is she happy now
no
[Music]
what's her reaction now
it's more intense
more intense yes good or bad
i would take it as bad
there are more interceptions that she's
suicidal
correct
joining us today is civil rights
attorney philip hamilton and terry
austin philip share his reaction to
finding the gun the defense and
prosecution are obviously going to argue
it differently but i want to know how do
you see it in connection to this case
i mean the finding of the gun is in many
respects critical i mean we know
ultimately that this death occurred in
2010 it took uh quite a few days
ultimately for you know mr wright's body
to be found but of course the gun is the
linchpin behind how we can ultimately
prove up the homicide and to the extent
that we had a cousin that helped
identify the gun within the lake it
gives a lot of corroboration to the
extent that the defense is going to try
to turn this on oh such and such is just
trying to make testimony in regards to
being able to get lesser time shaved off
or what have you this is a big
corroborating point so i think to the
extent that the gun has actually shown
up um it spells big problems for the
defense yeah now terry lorenzen wright's
mother the first witness on the stand as
we said how do you think her testimony
affected the jury
no question it had a huge impact on that
jury and it was a strategic move to put
the mother on the stand first it made a
lot of sense to me you could see that
she has been distraught ever since this
happened she started crying the second
she got up on that stand the judge
actually offered her tissues very good
judge by the way very even-handed with
both the defense and with the
prosecution but she was able to humanize
this particular victim obviously
everyone knows who lorenzen wright is
but she made him as her son and i think
everyone could absolutely relate to that
and she even had a point of levity when
she said she wanted him to continue in
school and he said he was going to make
a million dollars the whole jury laughed
when she said oh okay well then go play
basketball so she dehumanized him for
sure yeah definitely some touching
testimony there and of course you can
continue to watch tennessee the billy
reid turner hear the law and crime
network where we're providing gavel to
gavel coverage an update now to a
familiar story brought back into the
spotlight through the recent netflix
series inventing anna as fake heiress
anna sorkin faces deportation to germany
sorkin made headlines when her claims of
being a german heiress who lived a posh
new york lifestyle turned out to be a
swindling scheme she went by the name
anna delvey claiming she had more than
60 million dollar fortune overseas
prosecutors said she lied to stay at
high-end hotels for weeks at a time
falsified records and maneuvered her way
into new york social circles to have her
expenses covered in all they say sorakan
stole 275 thousand dollars sorkin was
convicted in 2019 but on monday she
filed papers seeking to hold off on
being deported orders which were signed
last month her attorney says they were
given a month to appeal that deadline
comes on thursday sorkin remains in ice
custody
in more celebrity legal news the
incident report is released in the death
of full house actor bob sackett this
after a florida judge rules all records
surrounding the investigation will be
permanently sealed sackett was found
dead in his orlando hotel room january 9
after failing to check out while
officials say foul play was not a factor
and that no one else was inside the room
at the time the circumstances
surrounding his death has caused a stir
across the internet the recently
released report says fractures around
the actor's eyes and bleeding around his
brain were likely caused when saga hit
his head on something hard covered in
something soft like a carpeted floor
saggett's family filed a lawsuit
requesting the release of any photos
videos or any other recordings related
to the investigation be prohibited a
florida judge made that permanent on
monday
still ahead on law and crime daily could
disgrace socialite elaine maxwell be
granted a new trial but first a
last-minute plea deal entered for
crystal daniels just before she was set
to stand trial the latest developments
in the murder of baby joe
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live lawn
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
mother charged in relation to her son's
disappearance entered into a no contest
agreement with tennessee prosecutors
wednesday as jury selection was set to
begin in the trial for crystal daniels
crystal's a second person charge in
connection to joe cly's disappearance in
2018 the boy's father joseph daniels was
already convicted of murdering their son
this past summer despite the child's
remains having never been found he is
presumed dead and there's no indication
crystal knows where her husband hid the
body crystal wasn't charging his
homicide prosecutors allege she did
nothing to protect joe clyde from joseph
when he was beating the boy to death on
wednesday she pled no contest to an
aggravated child abuse charge conspiracy
to commit aggravated child abuse false
reporting and tampering of evidence
we are starting the jury selection
process but i've been handed a document
indicating that an agreement
has been reached whereby the state and
the defense have agreed that miss
daniels may enter a no contest plea or
no low concentrate plea
to count
one
aggravated child abuse and receive a
sentence of 15 years to serve
count two
um
conspiracy to commit aggravated child
abuse receive a sentence of 12 years
to serve
count three
false report four years to serve count
four tampering with evidence six years
to serve
these would be served at 85
and they would be concurrent with one
another is that correct
so essentially an effective 15-year
service
all right back to break down daniel's
11th hour please civil rights attorney
phillip hamilton and terry austin terry
crystal daniel pleads no contest to
charges can you explain how that differs
from a guilty plea
right well when a defendant pleads
guilty they are admitting that he or she
committed that crime but when you plead
a no context you're neither accepting it
or rejecting it basically you're just
telling the court you're going to go
straight to jail you're not going to
fight the charges so the effects are
technically very close to the same
because they waive their jewelry right
in each case they have to knowingly and
willingly do it in each case so i think
most people don't even see the
difference but you're just not admitting
to that guilt when you are doing that no
contest it could have an effect in a
civil trial if it's a felony case then
it can't be held against you in a
misdemeanor but so that's where it comes
in yeah philip a number of charges
guilty of i think when you do the math
she's looking at about 15 years but the
major question is does the investigation
into where baby joe's body still
continue
i mean we'll ultimately see brian could
they potentially wave a carrot in front
of either crystal or her husband at this
point now that both of them have
essentially accepted culpability for
this even as terry noted that we don't
have an outright guilty plea from
crystal it's tantamount to as much
particularly when a mother at this point
is not fighting charges against the fact
that she in some way contributed to the
death of her son so to the extent that
maybe in some way some years could be
dangled in front of them to try in some
manner to you know reduce their
sentences we'll see ultimately if that
works but at this point uh i think the
prosecution has exactly what they wanted
from both of these parties
yeah and i mean
i'm hoping that that does happen that
that information is released in some way
shape or form
shave off a year or two years whatever
it is but i think
this young child needs a proper burial
so we'll keep eyes on this case
switching now to ohio where testimony
wednesday shifted away from victim
families members and back to health care
professionals in the trial for former
doctor william hussell a physician
charged in the death of over a dozen
patients prosecutors allege whoso
ordered fatal doses of fentanyl to be
given to patients under his care at
mount carmel hospital in columbus ohio
from 2015 to 2018. they say medication
altered the 14 patients causing death
who sells defense team argues the former
isu doctor was giving them end of life
comfort care on wednesday a former monk
carl
nurse testified to having discussions
with husel about working on being better
at discussions discussing the end of
life process with families he told
jurors husel had difficulty speaking in
groups and said his goal was to get
better at presenting publicative care
with families unm other medical
professionals also testified saying
whoso lied to a patient not named in
this case about which drug was being
administered testimony is expected to
continue in this case on thursday
coming up on law and crime daily accused
cult leader lawrence ray suffers
multiple seizures could that mean a
lengthy delay in the federal case
plus prosecutors and defense attorneys
clash over recent juror testimony will a
federal judge hand down a new trial for
elaine maxwell
[Music]
welcome back elaine maxwell should get a
new trial at least that's what her
defense attorneys are once again pushing
for and new arguments filed this week
this comes after a juror testified in a
post-trial hearing about his juror
questionnaire last week scotty david
testified he was distracted and quickly
filled out the questionnaire when he
failed to disclose his own history as a
victim of sexual abuse maxwell's defense
team argues that his grounds to vacate
the jury's guilty verdict federal
prosecutors argue david's testimony
shows he made an honest mistake and that
her verdict should stand they say it's
clear maxwell received a fair trial the
british socialite was convicted on six
counts in december of last year relating
to sex trafficking and grooming of young
girls prosecutors say maxwell helped
recruit underage girls for her companion
the late financer jeffrey epstein
maxwell faces 65 years in prison right
now sentencing for maxwell is set for
june
civil rights attorney philip hamilton
and terry austin uh join us again as we
discuss the potential new trial for key
lane maxwell terry what do you think of
the chances in terms of getting a new
trial is there actually enough to
overturn the conviction
i think there is enough to overturn it
listen
right now nathan has so much information
and could decide either way look as far
as what we know what happened in the
media we know that scotty david said he
influenced those jurors we know that he
said he talked about what happened to
him as a child he told them listen
believe these victims because it
happened to me that affected the
deliberation so right there as far as
i'm concerned i do believe it is a very
good reason to overturn this particular
conviction even though no one wants to
see this trial again so if it was an
honest mistake fine believe that but if
it affected the deliberations we need to
overturn that conviction
yeah i'm not the biggest fan of this uh
honest mistake argument from the
prosecutor philip let's ask you that's
what the federal prosecutors are calling
what scotty david did and then the
conviction should stand is that a strong
argument to you
it's not the strongest argument when
they are making the argument that it was
an honest mistake but of course
requested the court to provide this
juror with counsel for worry of the fact
that he may end up facing a perjury
charge from their same office so their
argument is contradicted a bit i think
in regards to whether or not that
ultimately leads to a new trial i think
judge nathan is going to very
meticulously work her way through this
in a way to try to find
her way out of having to order a new
trial i think of course that the effect
on the deliberations was probably
substantial however legally she's not
going to be able to look too deep into
that so she's going to look and
ultimately see did the fact that he lied
or made an honest mistake require a new
trial and i think legally it's going to
be an uphill battle for the government
yeah new trial no new trial i don't know
but make sure you continue to watch law
on crime daily we'll give you those
updates as they come in when we come
back disturbing video shows life on the
inside of the alleged sarah lawrence
college sex cult what shocking video
jurors are shown and why the trout could
be pushed back even farther
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
jury is seated but opening statements
are delayed in the federal trial of
one-time theron-o-c-o-o ramesh sunni
bhawani bohwani faces 12 federal fraud
charges in relation to his time with a
now defunct company founded by convicted
fraudster elizabeth holmes theranos was
touted as a company that would
revolutionize blood testing with its
state-of-the-art edison device later
tess found many problems with the device
in a federal trial spanning months
holmes point to the finger at balwani
her former boyfriend and therenose
business partner holmes testified that
bowani emotionally and physically abused
her and even forced her to have sex with
him against her will prosecutors
countered saying holmes knew about the
company's issues and lied her way into
millions of dollars in january federal
jury found holmes guilty on multiple
counts opening statements in bowani's
trial were expected to begin on
wednesday but were delayed when someone
in the courtroom had close contact to a
positive coven 19 case openings are now
set to be presented on friday
switching now to the east coast where
the federal trial of accused sarah
lawrence college cult leader is put on
hold after the defendant himself suffers
multiple seizures as long crime daily
reported court was delayed on thursday
when defendant lawrence ray suffered a
seizure in his jail cell that morning
after court resumed it was cut early
when rey was taken from the courtroom
onto a stretcher after suffering another
seizure in the afternoon ray stan's
trial on 17 counts including extortion
and racketeering stemming from the
alleged cult prosecutors say ray
inserted himself into a group of sarah
lawrence college students back in 2010
after moving in with his daughter who
was a student at the time after that
they say rey manipulated the students
forcing some into sex and prostitution
and even made makeshift therapy sessions
before court adjourned early on tuesday
jurors were shown first-hand video of
the manipulation and abuse
sit down and when you're going through
that shit
now we're gonna look to the bed all
right
is
get off with me
[Music]
troubling and disgusting video to say
the least philip i don't want to say a
former public defender because once a
public defender always a public defender
but you know what i mean i used to be a
public defender and you've seen some
serious cases are there any arguments
that you think the defense can make with
a straight face after the jury sees
these videos
i'll tell you right now as a former
public defender one of my former
colleagues is actually mr ray's current
attorney marty lennox and to the extent
that anyone is going to be able to turn
anything into a fight it's going to
ultimately be her at this point you just
hold the government to its burden you
don't have the best case it's clearly an
uphill battle for you to try to secure
any type of acquittal here but to the
extent that you can hold the government
legally to its case or some to prove it
beyond a reasonable doubt sometimes
that's all you can do and that's
ultimately most likely what miss linux
is going to do in this matter right
holding them to their burden and the
standard in the case we'll see how that
works out terry all this began when ray
moved into the dormitory at sarah
lawrence how is he able to move into a
dorm and do you think the school could
be held liable
absolutely i don't understand how he was
able to move into that dorm listen he
said he was going there to reunite and
reconnect with his daughter but what
school allows a father to move into a
dorm room basically the
rule should have been that no one can
live in that dorm unless you are a
student did they do a background check
we know that the federal authorities
have accused him of you know swindling
investors to the tune of 40 million
dollars we know that he has served jail
time so why was he even allowed did the
school do a background check and if they
didn't do any of those things obviously
these students have been harmed and the
parents or the students could bring
charges against him certainly negligence
in a civil suit yeah negligence
emotional distress i can see the list of
civil uh potential charges coming up but
we'll see how that develops well thank
you both and thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you